[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ihr seht es schon.
Was werden wir heute machen?
Josh?
>> JOSH: Buchteln!
>> SALLY: Buchteln!
Und weil sich viele herzhafte Buchteln gewünscht haben,
gibt es heute herzhafte Buchteln,
also salzig.
Ela fragt dann immer: "Warum heißt das herzhaft?"
Ja, weil es halt herzhaft ist.
Ich werde sie später füllen mit einer Hackfleisch-Pilz-Füllung.
Ihr könnt die aber füllen, womit ihr möchtet.
Ihr könnt Mozzarella und Tomate reingeben.
Ihr könnt das Ganze vegan auch zubereiten.
Ihr könnt wirklich machen, was ihr wollt.
Wir probieren es jetzt heute erst mal mit Hackfleisch-Pilz.
Und dafür werde ich jetzt den Hefeteig herstellen.
Und den könnt ihr wirklich als Basis für
alles nehmen, was einfach locker, fluffig und luftig sein soll.
Ich bin heute übrigens
nicht Karohemd-Sally, sondern
Streifenkleid-Sally.
Nur zur Info.
Ja.
Jetzt machen wir den Hefeteig.
Für den Hefeteig verwende ich
einen Würfel Hefe,
– das sind 42 Gramm –
20 Gramm Zuckerrübensirup,
150 Gramm warmes Wasser,
180 Gramm Buttermilch oder Kefir zum Beispiel,
zwei Eier,
750 Gramm Mehl,
zwei Teelöffel Salz
und 120 Gramm weiche Butter.
Das war es schon.
Ich habe die Zutaten immer da.
Das heißt, ich kann immer herzhafte Buchteln auch zubereiten.
Und statt Buttermilch, wie gesagt, auch Kefir oder Ayran
oder normale Milch, das geht auch alles.
Ihr könnt jetzt entweder einen Vorteig herstellen
oder direkt loslegen.
Ich lege jetzt direkt los.
Die Hefe ist da drin.
Zuckerrübensirup nehme ich hier jetzt ganz gern,
weil einfach die Farbe des Hefeteigs dann wunderschön wird.
Und das hat auch so einen leicht malzigen Geschmack.
Aber stattdessen könnt ihr auch Honig
oder Zucker zum Beispiel nehmen.
Dann das Wasser dazu.
Und geschwind verrühren.
Kurz verrühren.
Geschwind – sagt man das bei euch auch?
Geschwind?
Aylin, sagt man das bei euch?
>> AYLIN: Nein.
>> SALLY: Nein. Okay, man sagt es nur bei uns.
In Baden,
in Süddeutschland sagt man das so.
Ich erinnere mich noch an eine Situation
in der fünften Klasse Erdkunde.
Fragt mich mein Erdkundelehrer, der Herr Schäfer:
"Saliha,
wohnen wir auf der Nord- oder auf der Südhalbkugel?"
Und ich antworte:
"Südhalbkugel."
Und dann haben sie mich alle ausgelacht.
Ich habe es halt verwechselt mit Süddeutschland.
Kann ja mal passieren.
Aber die haben in der fünften Klasse
– wie kann man in der fünften Klasse ein Mädchen auslachen,
was eine Geografieschwäche hat?
Ich habe sie heute noch,
aber heute lache ich selber drüber.
Aber das war schon gemein.
Na ja...
Wie gesagt, wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr den Hefeteig
oder den Vorteig jetzt noch kurz aufgehen lassen.
Ich mache jetzt aber direkt weiter,
gebe jetzt hier die Flüssigkeiten dazu.
Bei Hefeteig einfach nur darauf achten:
Salz und Fett immer am Ende dazu geben,
damit es einfach nicht direkt an die Hefe dran geht
und die eben schön aufgehen kann.
Dann das Salz hier drauf.
Und ich gebe dann das Mehl langsam dazu.
Und je nach Mehlsorte kann es sein,
dass ihr ein bisschen mehr oder weniger braucht.
Und dann den Teig einfach etwa zehn Minuten kneten,
bis er schön geschmeidig ist.
Er darf nicht zu weich sein,
denn wir wollen ja Buchteln daraus kneten,
aber eben auch nicht zu fest.
Jetzt gebe ich auch direkt die Butter dazu.
Und ihr könnt ihn natürlich auch mit der Hand verkneten.
Es dauert halt nur ein
bisschen länger und ist ein bisschen aufwendiger.
[Musik]
Jetzt lasse ich den einfach kneten
und räume in der Zeit schon mal auf.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Hefeteig perfekt,
schön durchgeknetet.
Ihr könnt gern auch immer die Hände so leicht fetten.
[Musik]
Sehr schön.
Und jetzt nehme ich ihn kurz raus,
forme ihn zu einer Kugel.
Und dann darf er abgedeckt für eine Stunde aufgehen
oder in der Küchenmaschine
für eine Dreiviertelstunde bis Stunde
oder im Backofen bei Gärstufe
für eine halbe Stunde,
sodass er sich einfach schön verdoppelt.
Und ihr könnt bei der Menge an Mehl gerne auch
die Hälfte der Hefemenge benutzen.
Aber ihr müsst dann einfach nur wissen:
Je weniger Hefe, umso länger müsst ihr aufgehen lassen.
Also das ist einfach völlig normal.
Und ihr könnt auch bei diesen Rezepten
die selbst vermehrte Hefe benutzen.
Aber, wie gesagt, einfach die längere Aufgehzeit beachten.
Das ist dann schon wichtig.
[Musik]
Und dann gern die Oberfläche auch fetten
und aufgehen lassen.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Füllung zubereiten.
[Musik]
Für die Füllung nehme ich
zwei Esslöffel Olivenöl,
eine Zwiebel
und eine Knoblauchzehe,
500 Gramm Hackfleisch,
– ich habe es jetzt hier vom Rind –
250 Gramm Champignons,
40 Gramm Tomatenmark,
hier noch die Gewürze
Salz, Pfeffer,
Paprika in edelsüß
und Bergbohnenkraut
und 50 Gramm Schnittlauch.
Also das sind jetzt hier meine Zutaten.
Das Tomatenmark und den Schnittlauch,
das habe ich jetzt aus dem Gefrierfach.
Die habe ich nämlich immer auf Vorrat.
Denn ich habe mal
acht Kilo Schnittlauch geerntet
und das reicht mir jetzt wahrscheinlich für immer.
Na ja...
Was ich jetzt zuerst machen werde, ist,
das Olivenöl erwärmen.
Einfach in einer großen Pfanne.
In der Zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die Zwiebel
und die Knoblauchzehe fein hacken.
[Musik]
Dann das Hackfleisch hier direkt in der Pfanne anbraten.
Also schön krümelig anbraten.
Und immer gleich so zerteilen,
damit sich nicht so ein großer Klotz bildet.
[Musik]
Ich zeige euch hier mal kurz was,
weil ich ganz oft die Frage bekomme:
"Was passiert denn, wenn was im Gusseisentopf
oder in der Gusseisenpfanne anbrennt?"
Hier seht ihr,
dass am Anfang das Hackfleisch
hier so ein bisschen anbrennt
und zwar, weil ich da an der Stelle
jetzt einfach kein Fett hatte.
Hier sieht man ganz gut,
hier brennt es nicht an.
Aber das löst sich dann auch gleich
durch den Fleischsaft einfach wieder von ganz alleine.
Und oftmals ist es einfach so,
dass man dann entweder zu viel Hitze hat,
zu wenig Flüssigkeit oder Fett
oder eben einfach das falsche Gargut im Topf.
Und jetzt bei Hackfleisch zum Beispiel, wie gesagt,
hier kommt ja jetzt der Fleischsaft so ein bisschen raus
und das löst sich jetzt beim Kochen von alleine.
Wenn ihr das Problem öfter habt,
dann einfach mit mehr Flüssigkeit kochen
oder eben ein bisschen mehr Fett.
Weil das ist ja keine antihaftbeschichtete Pfanne.
Und normalerweise war es sogar immer so,
dass man Gusseisen
auch hat ein bisschen einbrennen lassen.
Und vielleicht kennt ihr es noch von eurer Oma
oder Uroma sogar.
Die hatte dann einen großen Gusseisenbräter
und der wurde dann auch immer
nur mit Wasser ausgewaschen
statt mit Spüli und mit Seife,
einfach, weil sich dann eben
irgendwann diese Beschichtung bildet.
Aber
man kann auch sauber arbeiten und sagen:
"Okay, ich wasche meine Töpfe lieber komplett aus
und will eben nichts
drin und keine Antihaftbeschichtung und keine Patina."
Dann muss man einfach beachten:
Nicht zu viel Hitze,
Feuchtigkeit oder eben genug Fett.
Bei mir ist das Hackfleisch jetzt schön krümelig.
Ich habe es jetzt hier übrigens auf Stufe 8 von 9.
Also ich mache da auch nicht auf volle Pulle,
weil das einfach zu heiß wird.
Das Material ist so ein schönes dickes, schweres Material
und da muss man echt nicht immer auf voller Pulle arbeiten,
nicht auf PowerBoost.
Jetzt gebe ich die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel dazu.
Die dürfen schön mitgaren,
bis sie weich sind, also bis sie glasig sind.
Da gebe ich einfach kurz den Deckel drauf,
rühre dann gleich noch mal durch.
Und das dauert so zwei bis drei Minuten.
Hier rühre ich ab und zu durch.
Ich habe die Hitze auch noch weiter runter gestellt,
damit nichts anbrennt.
Also ruhig so auf Stufe 5, 6.
Und jetzt kann ich in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Champignons fein hacken.
Die werden übrigens nicht gewaschen,
sondern nur geputzt.
Also Champignons einfach nicht waschen,
weil sie sich wirklich vollsaugen mit Wasser.
[Musik]
Jetzt die Champignons mitbraten.
Die haben ja jetzt auch noch Restfeuchtigkeit.
Das darf jetzt hier auch alles ein bisschen verkochen.
Das Tomatenmark dazu.
Und das habe ich, wie gesagt, vorher eingefroren.
Denn ich kaufe ganz gerne Tomatenmark
in so einer großen Verpackung,
packe es dann in meine Eiswürfelformen ein.
Und jetzt für euch habe ich es ausgepackt,
aber normalerweise gehe ich ans Gefrierfach,
und haue hier dann so zwei Eiswürfel rein
– also Tomatenwürfel.
Und dann habe ich das auch schon.
Jetzt kann ich auch direkt die Gewürze dazu geben,
als Salz, Pfeffer, Paprika und Bergbohnenkraut.
Das habe ich jetzt aus dem Garten.
Ihr könnt auch Oregano, Thymian, Majoran nehmen
und auch gerne scharfes Paprikapulver.
Aber ich koche ja nicht mehr so scharf,
seitdem die Kinder eben alles mitessen.
Und dann
versuche ich, mich so ein bisschen zurückzunehmen,
und schärfe lieber selber nach.
Und
den gebe ich zum Schluss dazu.
Also hier einfach nur noch ein bisschen köcheln,
bis die Champignons auch weich sind.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Also ich finde die Füllung jetzt wunderbar.
Abgeschmeckt habe ich sie schon mit Salz und Pfeffer.
Und jetzt...
Entschuldigung!
Ich hätte bitte gern eins.
Das ist mit Kresse?
>> AYLIN: Hm.
Und Salz.
>> SALLY: Ah, danke.
>> AYLIN: Bitte.
>> SALLY: Danke.
Und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht,
dass ich hier noch etwas Frischkäse dazu gebe,
damit es eine cremige Füllung wird.
Also noch 200 Gramm Frischkäse rein
und Schnittlauch.
Okay, es war jetzt ein bisschen verstörend, oder?
>> SARAH: Warum?
>> SALLY: Wir haben hier keinen Catering-Service.
Wir haben uns einfach Brote geschmiert
mit
– was ist es?
Roggenbrot mit Butter und Kresse und
Salz.
>> JOSH: Manchmal muss es gar nicht ausgefallen sein.
>> SALLY: Ja, manchmal müssen wir uns einfach
immer wieder neu erfinden
und zeigen, wie verrückt diese Welt hier ist.
Neulich schrieb eine so:
"Ich glaube, Sally ist schwanger.
Denn immer, wenn sie schwanger ist"
– immer, nicht? Immer!
Ich war erst zweimal schwanger.
>> SARAH: Alle hundert Mal.
>> SALLY: Alle hundert Mal.
"Denn immer, wenn sie schwanger ist,
wird sie verrückt und lustig."
Das stimmt gar nicht.
Dann lasse ich es nur raus aus mir.
Ich bin immer verrückt und lustig.
>> SARAH: So wie das Kind nach neun Monaten.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ja.
Also bitte lasst das!
Ich bin nicht schwanger!
Mein Gott!
Außerdem kann das voll verletzend sein.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ich würde versuchen, schwanger zu werden,
und es klappt nicht.
Und wenn man dann eine Frau immer wieder fragt,
das ist schon...
Also ich frage nie, ob jemand schwanger ist.
Denn ich kenne einfach zu viele Geschichten,
zu viele missglückte Schwangerschaftsversuche.
Ich finde das schon dann sehr traurig.
Aber nein, ich bin nicht schwanger.
Und nein, ich habe es auch nicht vor.
So.
Die Füllung lasse ich jetzt hier kurz stehen.
Der Hefeteig ist gleich so weit.
Und ich genieße solang mein Kressebrot.
[Musik]
Das ist er,
der gute Hefeteig.
Und ich nehme jetzt hier ein Emailleblech.
Das hat 32 cm im Durchmesser.
Also das ist das mittelgroße.
Hier habe ich noch etwas Butter
und kann es jetzt hier bei niedriger Stufe schmelzen.
Also wirklich niedrig.
1 oder 2 ist wirklich Maximum.
Und ich mache jetzt hier 20 Buchteln daraus.
Ein bisschen Mehl brauche ich schon,
ein bisschen Mehl.
Ein kleines bisschen Mehl brauche ich hier.
Und ich mache jetzt hier erst mal 20 Portionen.
So könnt ihr es euch super einteilen.
Wie wäre es, ich wiege ihn ab?
Ich wiege es ab. Dann muss ich nicht schätzen.
1440 Gramm
geteilt durch 20.
70.
Stimmt?
Ungefähr.
>> AYLIN: 72.
>> SALLY: Oh! Die waren sogar schon fast richtig!
Juhu!
Also ungefähr 72 Gramm.
[Musik]
Jetzt forme ich die noch zu schönen Kügelchen.
Heute kommt der Schwabe in mir durch, gell?
Immer mit Kügelchen.
Kügele.
>> JOSH: Ja, im Endeffekt machst du ja
runde Maultäschle, nicht?
>> SALLY: Maultäschle.
Herrgottsbscheißerle.
>> JOSH: Herrgottsbscheißerle.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Und dann
nehmt ihr euch ein Teigkügelchen,
öffnet es leicht,
nicht zu sehr.
Weil dann ist das Verschließen umso schwieriger.
So ungefähr handflächengroß.
Und ich nehme jetzt den mittleren Eisportionierer
– ich hoffe, dass das jetzt von den Portionen her gut aufgeht –
so leicht gehäuft
und gebe jetzt die Füllung in die Mitte
und verschließe die Buchtel ganz vorsichtig.
Einfach mit den Fingern zupfen.
So.
Und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch vorher
diese Kugeln geformt,
damit die Buchteln auch eine schöne glatte Oberfläche haben.
Ansonsten mache ich es meist so,
dass ich es einfach aus der Form direkt
forme.
Mit der Zeit hat man da auch echt die Übung.
Und dann geht das auch immer besser.
Und ich kenne auch eine Version,
da nimmt man das Hackfleisch roh,
vermischt alles roh miteinander,
formt kleine Bällchen und gibt sie dann rein.
Aber dann ist es halt so:
Wenn man Ende reinbeißt, hat man so,
ja, wie so eine Frikadelle drin.
Und die ist mir dann zu fest.
Also so finde ich es schon schön und cremig.
Und deswegen finde ich das Kochen vorher auch ganz okay.
Es dauert zwar kurz,
aber man überbrückt ja sowieso die Wartezeit.
Von daher finde ich das okay.
Ich mag es halt lieber cremig, die Füllung.
So ein bisschen wie Poğaça,
wie türkisch, wie diese kleinen Teigtaschen.
[Musik]
Und hier ist es ja meist so,
dass hier die Oberfläche leicht antrocknet
und dann eben nicht mehr so klebt.
Das heißt, ihr nehmt die Unterseite,
legt die auf die flache Hand,
drückt das dann schön auseinander.
Weil jetzt klebt praktisch die Innenfläche an meiner Hand.
Und jetzt drehe ich es aber um,
damit die klebrige Seite innen ist.
Dann lassen sie sich nämlich super verschließen
und die Oberfläche ist aber dann schön angetrocknet.
Guckt. Und dann klebt es immer schön
gleich zusammen.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier das Blech mit der Butter.
Und wisst ihr was?
Da nehmt ihr jetzt ein bisschen was von der Butter,
streicht sie auch an den Rand.
>> JOSH: Der nächste Butterkuchen.
>> SALLY: Das ist kein Butterkuchen.
Das sind Buchteln.
Jetzt lege ich die erste in die Mitte
und dann einfach in drei Reihen drumherum.
Gucken wir mal, wie es reinpasst.
Also normalerweise werden Buchteln
dann noch mit Butter bestrichen.
[Musik]
Ja, so ist es doch schön.
>> JOSH: Das ist wirklich ein Dream.
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> JOSH: Ein Dream. Ein Dream.
>> SALLY: Dream, nicht?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben.
Ja.
Vielleicht doch noch ein bisschen Butter obendrauf?
>> SARAH: Hau drauf!
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen Butter muss noch obendrauf.
Es tut mir leid, aber...
>> SARAH: Heute haben wir eh Butter-Overload.
>> SALLY: Ich habe noch Butter da.
Also ein bisschen geschmolzene Butter obendrauf.
Was ist heute los hier? Was ist heute los hier?
Aha!
Kaum gibt es Essen, kommt der Murat.
Oh wow!
Oh wow! Das sieht aus wie ein schönes Bild.
Ich habe euch Buchteln gemalt.
Oh, guck mal, wie schön die aussehen!
Schon schön.
Sollen wir sie noch bestreuen?
>> SARAH: Sesam.
>> SALLY: Ich gucke in meine Schublade.
>> SARAH: Sesam oder Mohn.
>> JOSH: Mohn.
>> SARAH: Mohn oder...
>> SALLY: Wisst ihr was? Ich erfülle euch jeden Wunsch.
Ich nehme Sesam und Mohn.
[Musik]
Ich gebe die Buchteln jetzt in den kalten Backofen.
Ihr könnt sie auch gerne vorher einfach aufgehen lassen
abgedeckt eine halbe Stunde,
damit sie einfach schön luftig werden,
und dann im heißen Backofen backen
oder eben, wie gesagt, die Aufheizzeit einfach nutzen.
Ich stelle jetzt hier ein 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Und während der Ofen dann aufheizt,
können die Buchteln aufgehen
und backen dann eben auch gleichzeitig.
Wenn ihr einen Dampfbackofen habt,
könnt ihr auch noch Dampfstufe 1 einstellen
oder einfach so backen.
Und ich denke, so 35 bis 40 Minuten,
dann sind sie fertig.
Und wenn ihr das in einem heißen Backofen macht,
sind es 25 bis 30
ungefähr.
35 bis 40,
25 bis 30.
Ja.
Zehn Minuten.
Ich habe gerade überlegt:
"35 bis 40 und jetzt zehn Minuten weniger.
25 bis 30."
Und dann war ich total verwirrt.
Ojemine!
Ich rechne einfach nicht mehr live.
Wobei Mathe echt eine Stärke von mir war.
[Musik]
Die Buchteln sind gebacken.
Ich habe sie jetzt hier noch
ein bisschen zum Abkühlen zur Seite gestellt.
Und jetzt gibt es noch eine Aioli dazu.
Aioli, das ist im Prinzip so was wie eine Mayonnaise,
aber mit viel Knoblauch.
All i oli, Knoblauch und Olivenöl müsste es heißen.
Im Prinzip, wie gesagt, eine Mayonnaise.
Sie besteht aus Ei, Öl und Knoblauch
fast zu gleichen Teilen.
Also es schmeckt wirklich superlecker.
Die Zubereitung ist auch ganz einfach.
Ihr müsst nur beachten, dass das Ei frisch ist,
weil es eben roh verzehrt wird.
Für die Aioli verwende ich
drei Knoblauchzehen,
ein Ei,
einen Esslöffel Essig,
einen halben Teelöffel Zucker,
einen Teelöffel Senf,
Salz und Pfeffer
und 250 Gramm Rapsöl.
Ihr könnt Rapsöl nehmen oder Olivenöl
– Olivenöl schmeckt natürlich etwas stärker im Geschmack –
oder Sonnenblumenöl.
Also da entscheidet ihr einfach selbst.
Ich gebe jetzt zuerst das Ei in eine Rührschüssel.
Bei mir haben jetzt alle Zutaten Zimmertemperatur.
Dann kommt der Essig dazu.
Ich habe jetzt hier einen Apfelessig.
Dann Zucker.
Senf.
[Musik]
Salz und Pfeffer.
Jetzt werden die Zutaten so lange gemixt,
bis die Eiermasse einfach schön weißcremig ist.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt dafür übrigens,
wenn ihr das sehen könnt,
nicht die Mixmesser.
Die könnt ihr auch nehmen,
aber ich habe hier einfach noch
ein zusätzliches Teil obendrauf für Milchschaum.
Und ich glaube, für Mayonnaise ist das auch ganz gut.
Schneebesen geht auch.
Hauptsache, es wird schnell gerührt.
Hier ist im Prinzip auch wichtig,
dass ihr ein hohes Rührgefäß habt,
damit ihr einfach diese wenige Masse
eben auch schön aufschäumen könnt.
Das geht in einem flachen Gefäß nicht so gut.
Und deswegen kippe ich das hier auch,
damit ich einfach die ganze Masse
direkt unter diesem Rührelement habe
und dann eben alles schön schaumig schlagen kann.
[Musik]
Und jetzt langsam,
wirklich langsam,
das Öl zugießen,
damit das Eigelb das Öl aufnehmen kann
und es homogen wird und sich nicht absetzt.
Und dadurch wird die Konsistenz jetzt fester
und cremeartiger.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Eine richtig schöne Creme.
Falls sie euch doch mal nicht gelingt
und sie wirklich gerinnt oder nicht so wirklich zusammenhält,
könnt ihr auch noch mal ein Eigelb dazu geben.
Das Eigelb hilft dann, dass die Masse sich schön verbindet.
Aber, wie gesagt, wenn ihr alles schön langsam macht,
die Zutaten alle zimmerwarm sind,
ihr fleißig rührt
und die Eiermasse schaumig schlagt,
dann kann eigentlich nichts schiefgehen.
Am Anfang sieht es echt so aus, als würde es nicht klappen,
aber es klappt.
Vertraut mir.
Und, damit das jetzt eine Aioli wird
und keine langweilige Mayonnaise,
kommen jetzt noch die Knoblauchzehen mit rein.
Beim Stabmixer mit Mixaufsatz einfach
die Mixer, die Messer benutzen
oder einfach fein dazu reiben
oder mit der Knoblauchpresse dazu geben.
[Musik]
Also die Creme ist nichts für Leute,
die noch einen Zahnarzttermin haben am gleichen Tag
oder am nächsten oder übernächsten.
So.
Abfüllen und probieren.
[Musik]
Sorry. Wir müssen jetzt halt vor dem Probieren singen.
>> SARAH: Ich werde gezwungen.
Sie zwingt mich.
[Musik]
So.
>> SALLY: Ich finde, wir sollten jedes Rezept
mit
>> SARAH: Gesanglich untermauern.
>> SALLY: einem Karaoke-Gesang untermauern
und probieren.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> AYLIN: Ich finde, wir sollten einfach probieren.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> AYLIN: Darf ich?
Ja.
>> SALLY: Die habe ich aufgerissen.
Das ist meine.
>> AYLIN: Okay.
>> SALLY: Hier. Ihr reißt euch eine eigene auf.
>> SARAH: Darf ich selber? Einfach mit der Hand?
>> SALLY: Ja, einfach aufreißen.
>> AYLIN: Müssen wir keine Fotos mehr machen?
>> SALLY: Haben wir doch.
>> SARAH: Nee, ich habe Fotos.
>> AYLIN: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ja. Hier, nehmt euch eine Ganze. Hier.
Die kann man so wegreißen.
>> SARAH: Okay.
Aber dann passt sie nicht in die Aioli rein.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> AYLIN: Das klang, glaube ich, echt.
>> SALLY: Woah!
>> SARAH: Knoblauch?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Flo, es tut mir leid.
>> SALLY: Aber richtig gut!
>> AYLIN: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Woah!
>> SALLY: Und, o mein Gott, die sind so
luftig!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> AYLIN: Genau.
>> SALLY: So – ich hasse das Wort – fluffig!
>> AYLIN: Die sind echt
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> AYLIN: sehr lecker!
>> SARAH: Aber es stimmt.
>> SALLY: Die sind richtig...
>> SARAH: Die sind megafluffig.
>> SALLY: Die sind richtig perfekt.
>> SARAH: Und ich hatte noch nie herzhafte Buchteln.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> AYLIN: Ich habe auch so lang auf das Rezept gewartet.
>> SARAH: Aber ich favorisiere es
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: vor süßen
>> SARAH: mit Aioli.
Tschau, Leben!
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
>> AYLIN: Hm.
>> SALLY: Tschau, Leben!
>> SARAH: Tschau, Leben!
>> AYLIN: Da ist schon gut viel Knoblauch drin.
>> SALLY: Ein bisschen.
>> AYLIN: Ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Und macht das Rezept so
– also macht es nach mit drei Knoblauchzehen.
>> SARAH: Ich habe überall Aioli!
>> SALLY: Ich hatte das auch vorhin überall auf der Schürze.
Oh, da kannst du eine Woche
nicht mehr aus dem Haus gehen!
>> SARAH: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Außer alle Menschen essen Knoblauch.
>> AYLIN: Superlecker!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Woah!
>> SALLY: Ich meine,
die Aioli...
>> SARAH: Ich fühle es.
>> SALLY: Die Aioli war ja
auf drei Schälchen aufgeteilt.
Das heißt, in einer Schale haben wir jetzt
eine Knoblauchzehe.
>> SARAH: Das ist ordentlich.
>> SALLY: Ich feiere es auch.
>> SARAH: Ordentlich!
>> AYLIN: Macht nichts.
>> SARAH: Aber Knoblauch ist gesund.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Sehr gesund.
Ist es nicht entzündungshemmend?
>> SALLY: Anti-
Genau.
>> SARAH: Ja.
So.
>> SALLY: Und gut für das Herz.
Mmh!
Hält den Kreislauf in Schwung.
Wow!
Also wir genießen unsere Aioli weiter.
>> SARAH & AYLIN: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aioli mit ein bisschen Buchteln.
Wow! Echt lecker!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> AYLIN: Auf jeden Fall nachmachen!
>> SALLY: Definitiv nachmachen!
>> AYLIN: Die sind echt perfekt!
>> SALLY: Wir machen sie auch noch mal öfter jetzt.
>> SARAH: Haut rein!
Deshalb drehe ich mich übrigens immer um.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Sarah schmatzt und schlürft und tut.
>> SALLY: Jetzt hast du auf der Lippe Aioli
>> SARAH: Das ist halt so lecker!
>> SALLY: und zwischen den Zähnen Mohn.
>> AYLIN: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Tschau!
Tschau!
[Musik]